dicke challenger doch der wendler denn
der muss raus aus seinem haus also auch
dass nach der pleite sänger er hatte
sich trotz haushoch schulden irgendwie
noch eine traumvilla in florida
geleistet da hat er jetzt samt seiner
laura seine sachen packen müssen das
berichtet bild jetzt exklusiv
schnelle boote teure taschen schicke
essen von bescheidenheit oder gar
sparmaßnahmen ist bei michael wendler
und laura müller nichts zu sehen und das
trotz seiner steuerschulden in
deutschland die wendlers leben in saus
und braus bis jetzt wie bild exklusiv
erfuhr wurde der mietvertrag ihrer
traumvilla in südflorida nicht
verlängert das bestätigte die
vermieterin auf nachfrage für die
wendlers heißt es also sachen packen und
raus aus ihrem haus online wird das
mietshauses unter gordon angeboten vier
schlaf drei badezimmer und insgesamt
228 quadratmeter umfasst das objekt
außerdem gibt es einen pool und der pool
wird vom eigentümer übernommen das alles
gibt es für
6500 euro im monat aber eben nicht mehr
für den wendler und seine frau laura
laut bild informationen ist das ehepaar
bereits ausgezogen und das obwohl die
miete bereits beim einzug bis zum 30 9
2009 22 bezahlt wurde es ist der zweite
umzug innerhalb eines jahres erst im
vergangenen jahr verkaufte der wendler
sein haus in cape coral für 890.000
dollar und hatte große pläne statt seine
schulden zu tilgen kaufte er sich ein
grundstück um ein neues haus zu bauen
nach bild recherchen wurde bisher
allerdings noch kein bauantrag für das
grundstück gestellt dort finden die
wendlers also keinen unterschlupf
[Musik]
mit reporterin kate die pfleger jetzt
bei uns live dort wo der wendler
rausgekickt wurde katy bringen uns
einmal schnell auf den stand warum denn
warum wollte man den wendler da nicht
länger wohnen lassen
ja so michael wendler laura war sehr
unbeliebten der in der nachbarschaft das
hat sich oft an abmachungen nicht
gehalten da es gab viele die mit einigen
nachbarn gesprochen haben sich beschwert
haben gesagt sie hatten gewisse aussagen
die für die ganze community für die
nachbarschaft gelten nicht bezahlen sie
werden außerdem sehr zurückgezogen
hätten sie gelebt und das ist eine sehr
neue nachbarschaft das heißt die leute
sind dauert innerhalb der letzten zwei
jahre eingezogen sind komplett neue
häuser und man möchte halt dass man eine
nachbarschaft freundschaft hat dass man
miteinander umgeht und die haben sich
sehr zurückgezogen und das kam bei
vielen leuten nicht gut an
auf einmal waren sie dann becker sowie
gesagt damit ging auch noch bis ende
september
die sind allerdings vor ein paar wochen
ein alters kann man umzugswagen hat mir
ein nachbar erzählt und innerhalb von
drei tagen war das haus komplett lehmann
hat michael mädler und laura seitdem nie
wieder gesehen was ganz besonders
interessant war ich habe mit der
schwester des vermieters des
hausbesitzers gesprochen und dann hören
wir es mal an was sie gesagt habe er ist
weg es ist das haus von meinem bruder
hat sondern vermietet und ist gegangen
du weißt nicht warum es gab einfach kein
christ einfach gegangen vor ablauf des
mietvertrages wir wissen es nicht es ist
es irgendwas passiert
wir wissen nichts wir bekamen eine
andere vom pulver und da sagt er ist weg
wir waren auch geschockt mein gott wir
sind froh dass er weg ist es war ein
albtraum war es vorher schlimm also war
ein schlechter mieter kein kommentar
kein
kommentar ja das ist der absolute
wahnsinn also michael wendler hat nicht
mal sein vermieter bescheid gegeben ich
sie jetzt aus ich sie einen monitor
eineinhalb monate früher aus sondern hat
aber seine sachen gepackt und es
gegangen und dann hat eben der pool
balls er danach dem pool schauen wollte
gesehen dass das haus komplett leer ist
und keiner weiß wo die beiden sind es
wie gesagt jahren davor zwar nicht
besonders nachbarschaftlich mit den
anwohnern aber nicht mal bescheid zu
sagen
es gibt eine deutsche- die wohnt direkt
gegenüber habe ich auch gesprochen und
sie martina sie hat immer noch ein paket
das sie für laura angenommen plattform
amazon oder was auch immer und das wurde
bis jetzt noch nicht abgeholt und es gab
viele unstimmigkeiten bei der nachbarn
die nachbarin sonja die deutsche hat
erzählt dass laura anscheinend oft nackt
im garten rumgelaufen wäre es sehr zum
unwillen der nachbarn weil diese häuser
sind dort sehr offen es gibt keine
grünen mauern oder irgendwelche grenzen
das heißt man kann auf den teller des
nachbarn schauen und viele junge
familien mit kleinen kindern und das war
natürlich sehr zum unwillen und viele
leute man da einfach sehr wütend darüber
naja stand jetzt haben sie ja kein dach
über den kopf das heißt wo schlafen die
beiden denn
ja das ist die große frage sondern hat
sie nicht mehr gesehen man weiß auch
nicht sie haben wir dieses grundstück
gekauft aber dort haben sie noch nicht
gebaut aber ich habe jetzt von allen
fotografen gehört der gesagt hat sie vor
ein paar wochen bei einem lagen beide mo
wohnmobil verkäufer gesehen die haben
sich dort nach einem mobilen umgeschaut
und man hat ja auch gesehen voll paar
tagen hat laura fotos aus new york
gepostet dass es könnte sein dass sie
ist komplett mobil boner so nomadenleben
führen alles aufgegeben haben und jetzt
einfach mit dem wohnmobil vielleicht
durch amerika ziehen also der wendler
der unter die camper geht jetzt
neuerdings danke kate die pfleger unsere
bild reporterin dort wo der wendler
gerade rausgekickt wurde ich fand das
mit dem paket super interessant wollen
wir das nicht zustellen katie also nimm
dir das amazon paket und wir stellen dem
wendler zu wo immer er ist wendler soll
sich melden bild stellt das letzte paket
zu danke katie danke dir
[Musik]